this will really be if not a deathblow
then certainly a very severe boats the
whole idea that the federal government's
powers are limited and that it's not the
case that the federal government can do
pretty much whatever it wants hi I'm
Zach Weiss Muller with Reason TV
we're here with Ilyas Selman a professor
of law at George Mason University a
writer for the popular vote conspiracy
and author of an amicus brief in the US
Department of Health and Human Services
versus the state of Florida which is a
challenge to the Affordable Care Act and
will be heard in the Supreme Court this
March oh yeah thank you very much for
joining us tonight thank you so much
very happy to be here your particular
amicus brief really focuses in on the
individual mandate yes why is that the
individual mandate is probably the
single biggest issue that's at stake in
this case what the individual mandate
does is it requires virtually all
Americans to buy government-approved
health insurance by 2014 this is
important for two reasons one is that
this is a very important piece of
legislation in and of itself it has a
huge potential impact second it's
important down the line because if the
federal government wins this litigation
then they will have the power not just
to impose the individual mandate but
also to impose almost any other kind of
mandate the Congress might care to adopt
even the broccoli mandate that many
people have talked about requiring
people to buy broccoli and could you
explain to us what the broccoli mandate
is a lot of people have been talking
about that the same kind of reasoning
that the federal government is using to
claim that the health insurance mandate
is permissible under the Constitution
could equally well justify a mandate
requiring people to buy broccoli or to
buy a car a movie ticket Harry Potter
novelist pretty much anything you want
the exact same reasoning would justify
these other kinds of mandates the
objection you hear from the other side
is that when you talk about MIT the
government mandating that we all eat
broccoli it's never going to happen
that's totally ridiculous and we have to
trust Congress to be able to make
reasonable legislation why is that not a
fair
rebuttal to that if we really believe
that we can trust Congress why not why
have any constitutional limits on
government power at all you can always
say well we don't need those limits
because the politicians are reasonable
or if they're not the voters will punish
them for doing bad things
the fact that a matter is that both
Congress and state legislatures have a
long history of abusing their powers
that's one of the reasons why we need
constitutional limits on government
power
moreover the problem that you have here
is that actually there's a lot of
industries that have a lot of lobbying
power and a lot of interest group clout
that could promote mandates for
themselves and all of them many of them
at least could tell a plausible story
about why this is somehow in the public
interest
you want a broccoli mandate you make fun
of it but actually broccoli is good for
you right and there's a lot of data
which says that your diet actually has a
much bigger effect on how healthy you
are than even the kind of medical care
the medical care you get so Congress
could plausibly say well maybe not a
broccoli mandate but we have a health
food purchase mandate says part of our
program to try to reduce obesity and
improve health and that will actually
save on health care costs your brief
focuses a lot on what's called the
Necessary and Proper Clause in the
Constitution the Congress shall have
power to make all laws which shall be
necessary and proper for carrying into
powers vested by the Constitution in the
government why does the Necessary and
Proper Clause play a big role in your
brief the Necessary and Proper Clause is
one of three arguments that the federal
government is making claiming that this
was within the power allocated to
Congress by the Constitution
unfortunately the Supreme Court has for
a long time now defined necessary as not
the way you and I use the word necessary
something that's actually really needed
but as just anything that might be in
some way useful or convenient for
carrying into execution one of the other
powers which of course could be almost
anything the point that we make in our
brief is that although it may be that
almost anything can be considered
necessary including the individual
mandate it doesn't follow that it's also
proper remember it's the Necessary and
Proper Clause not just the necessary
clause is there really a legal
definition
of what is proper I mean haven't we
already gone beyond all sense of
propriety and government action the
Supreme Court has never in 200 years
given us a definitive statement on what
is meant by proper but they have said in
several cases that the requirement of
propriety is separate from that of
necessity so even something which is
necessary need not be proper exactly
what proper means is a complex question
but in our brief we focus on one crucial
aspect of it which is that at the very
least a wah is improper if the argument
in favor of it would give Congress
virtually unlimited power to do almost
anything it wants because if Congress
has virtually unlimited power that makes
a hash of the entire balance between the
states and a federal government and it
also renders many of Congress's other
lists of enumerated powers completely
superfluous okay I think a lot of people
think that the government's already
there they already control so much of
our activity what is it about the
individual mandate that is somehow
different in in kind then what the
government does now with the individual
mandate what is being regulated well
it's simply the state of not having
health insurance and when you don't have
health insurance that's not producing a
commodity it's not consuming a commodity
and it's currently isn't distributing a
commodity so even under Gonzalez vs.
race which is a very broad I think very
wrongheaded decision nonetheless you
would have to go even farther than that
there's been a lot of talk about the
Gonzalez versus Reyes case the medical
marijuana case because Scalia came down
with the majority in that case and
people think that that indicates he is
going to possibly rule in favor of
upholding the individual mandate he may
or he may not but it's very easy to
distinguish the two cases in their view
having this medical marijuana is
economic activity they define economic
activity as the production consumption
or distribution of a commodity that's
very broad I think that decision is a
terrible decision but even that doesn't
go far enough to justify the individual
mandate in his concurring opinion in the
race case his separate opinion where he
said I don't agree with the majority's
reasoning but I do agree the law is
constitutional he
used the word activity 42 times in
describing what it is that Congress has
the power to regulate here they're not
regulating any kind of pre-existing
activity for just regulating the state
of not having health insurance which is
really a form of inactivity I think
Scalia got it wrong and race he should
have voted the other way but he can
easily vote to strike down the mandate
without taking back anything that he
said in Raich and perhaps he will do
that another big claim from the other
side is that the health care market is a
special market because everyone is
inevitably going to need health care so
actually by mandating everyone buy
health care it does not necessarily
affect the regulations in other markets
do you think that that is valid or is
there something wrong with that logic
yes there is something wrong with the
logic namely that the exact same logic
can be used to justify any other mandate
notice the bait and switch here that
they're shifting to focus from health
insurance which is what you're actually
being required to buy and everybody
knows that not everybody uses health
insurance if they did we wouldn't need
to mandate in the first place
- instead of switching to focus - health
care and a similar bait and switch can
justify any other mandate let's consider
a car purchase mandate not everybody
drives cars but everybody is in the
market for transportation even if you
just walk around you're using shoes to
help propel you right now if this ruling
goes against you what negative
consequences might we expect this will
really be if not a death blow then
certainly a very severe boats the whole
idea that the federal government's
powers are limited and that it's not the
case that the federal government can do
pretty much whatever it wants and I
think in a constitutional system of
government where we have good reasons
for distrusting the political process
and distrusting politicians and the like
that that's not a desirable outcome and
it's also not an outcome that's
consistent with the letter or the
original meaning or the spirit of the
Constitution are you optimistic that the
courts going to give a good ruling on
this I'm more optimistic than I used to
be but I still think the odds are more
against us than in favor of us because
if you look at who's on the Supreme
Court right now the four most liberal
justices have made it clear that they
are not willing to impose any
significant structural limits on federal
our so we would have to win every single
one of the five other justices to get
the majority we need those five
conservative justices have sort of been
fractious on these issues and if we lose
even one of them then we lose the case
that said however I think we do have a
decent shot I think if you look at some
of their statements over the last
several years it's clear that those
justices including the key swing wood or
Justice Kennedy do not want to create a
situation where the federal government
has unlimited power so it seems likely
that they would only vote to uphold the
mandate if they thought that there's a
way to do so without licensing virtually
all other mandates